servus und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute spielen wir ja blick
mit dem spielen heute die folgende
challenge ich entweder heute verts
willing du bist da drüben spielen heute
eine change die wir so ähnlich schon bei
wenig gemacht hat auch nicht ganz genau
so wie spielen ist heute folgendermaßen
wir beide laufen die deppen ranz und
immer wenn einer von uns runter fällt
muss er dem anderen bescheid geben und
dann zu dem zeitpunkt muss der andere
auch in den abgrund sprechen das heißt
wir müssen immer genau zeitgleich fehlen
und ich bin mal sehr gespannt wie weit
wir damit kommen also ich würde erstmal
bomben safe spielen heißt wir hätten
wahrscheinlich intercell die heim in
kamien alter ist nicht mal aufgefallen
ist systems teile also die schuhe
geputzt die hatten jump pro unter dir
als crew erwartet kommt man meinen
ersten song verdammt wenig kriegst
nehmen
es gibt ja übrigens nicht verstanden was
wir damit meint führen 0 jump fällt so
einer runde ein diadem am ende das heißt
man kann theoretisch zwei mann fällt der
putz unten die erhält man finde ich mir
vermittelt du musst jetzt sehr genau
wenn du kannst du dir wenn du keine böse
ist
ich spiele nicht so ruhig dass ich immer
dass ich nur jumps mache ich bin
meistens relativ schnell aber ich bin
nicht sohn james unterwegs also wie ich
dass ich das geschafft habe ich auch
eine mega türlich gründe gehabt
eigentlich das weiter gespielt und habe
einfach mit saps gespielt als ob die
eingeladene von lollipop solutions
vorgelesen alles beim modul acht komme
ich drauf leute ich hab ein shampoo und
dann aber durch gedanke das schwitzen
aber dann habe ich weiß nicht mal eine
technik um bei diesem 1
machst du denn bei dem turm wurde von
einem bruder peter auf dieses eine ist
genau dann gehst du ganz an den rand
also ganz zu ecke durch den blumen
herford einfach und dann guckt
in etwa auf das gäste drauf springt
links ob man direkt also genau dann
stehst du vor bringst du springst du
four aus dem stand aus dem stand zu
stand ok und wehrtechnik
das heißt du warst schon bei der kiste
gerade eben alter würde ich bestimmt
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ich hab die einbände öffentlichkeit
natürlich richtig natürlich hat der
junge joel die einwände
bevor ich jetzt eine richtige blockade
mal irgendwo im fall das ganze zeit
unter anderem das ist halt das große
risiko dass das große risiko der
challenge ist das war alles video module
jetzt die letzten 25 verstärkt
ja ja tatsächlich irgendetwas zu viele
medien module die richtig schwierig sie
sind ja es gibt auch dieses eine mutter
mit den unsichtbaren blöcken weiß
welches das ist mittel mit dem brander
das ist so wenig geholfen das ist so
eklat wer ist auf die schnaps bekommen
das als medium einzuführen das video
alter das war vor dem vorher hatte die
kommission hat ja und du weißt du da
gibt es ein anderes mit unsichtbaren
blöcken mit den richtig was ist schade
und natürlich gut finde es gut ich
könnte den erfolg und viel spaß im leben
tore gefallen dahinter wartet jetzt kurz
nicht fertig bin kurz vor finde ich in
diesem langen modul ja ich kann es gar
nicht einfach in die ecke stellen
beruhigen kurz trinken tee und
checkpoint charlie in dieser folge um du
musst diese so springen mit diesem
dreier treten da ja klar wenn du drei
blöcke erst zurück
aber dieses andere da beamten also auf
einem blog damit habe ich immer noch
nicht hinbekommen
das hab ich irgendwie gelernt einfach
videos
nein ich halte die ganze berühmte aber
halt nicht ganz unter sondern immer nur
außerhalb der säule wieder außerhalb und
auch der leiter also ich bin immer ich
bin ganz raus braucht dann komme ich
raus
wie kann man den sprung ins all startet
wieder langsam vom ok kurz nicht fällt
bei mir sitzt gerade relativ gut aus ich
bin wieder am träger ich bin ich bin ab
diesem diese auf diese säule kurzform
jackpot jetzt nicht fällen nicht fehlen
einfach gar nicht fehlen aber das wird
richtig vergeht aber es ist das
schwieriger leicht haben
was hast du denn gern das ist eins mit
zu verschiedenen farbigen claim-blöcken
wo man an einer stelle soll und die
blöcke herum springen muss ich bin kurz
vor welche unter gefallen ich mal so ich
fahre immer so dass ich heute vor diese
sei aber groß der schmerz kommt das feld
kommt okay aber ich kann ein modul 9
noch findet notiert ist fürs ego ich
habe einfach ich hab' ich hab jetzt aber
ist notiert
wieso geht eigentlich immer wieder in
not team reiten
wir können sie nicht angriffspakt
schließen das ist das geschichte des
zweiten weltkriegs aber nicht über den
themen bio ja wissen muss ein ende haben
die u20 pfeile für den fall dass doch
irgendwie angreifen willst als ob man
jemand gegen die cia kannst du alles
kann ich habe ich hatte ich habe in
einem schwert in der runde durch
hierhin hatte und ich hatte fast in gold
abgelegt aber das ist so
floris montana sid ich hab' ich hab mir
mal einen spieler die letzten die wir
gespielt haben um ihrem kanal das war ja
die mit dieser ähnlichen challenger auf
der messe wider
damit wurde einer verzauberten drogen
und sperren ab aber ich meine wir haben
auch eine rose gespielt und mit ihr
aufzunehmen haben oder wo die kam wo wir
gegen den typen gespielt haben da
einfach display kruse und schwert
verzauberte
kann sein aber das passiert mir öfters
das ich 33 level hat es ist richtig sei
also keine ahnung wer also du brauchst 2
level tanzen aber dass ein level
entscheidend machen das doch nur ein
leben ab und du kannst die sache ist du
kannst rüstung mit nur einem level
verzaubern
okay wer gut erwischt
alles klar okay du bist du bist am leben
getrackt altert nhl wir nicht denn der
11.11 herzen wie auf dem boden verteilt
aber tnt darf man erfolgt darf man nicht
aber tnt in minecraft macht denn so was
schade
ja ich bin ich reingekommen also ich hab
mich drauf gestellte herab das loch
nicht gefunden
minecraft wissen minecraft wissen hektar
erst profi von einer brüstung dich
geholt weiß noch wie er mich geholt
hatte jetzt hat auch dich geholt und
zwar genau so leute
den lauf gegen den zaun aber der zaun
lässt sich nicht mehr frei
das was von einer folge minecraft mit
der beschreibung ist